Mahinda Rajapaksa is not running for
president he's already served the
maximum two terms yet he's the man these
people have waited hours in the rain to
see it's his older less charismatic
brother got a buyer who's on the ballot
politics is a family business for the
Rajapaksa s-- got abaya announced his
candidacy after the Easter Sunday
suicide bombings that targeted churches
and hotels killing 263 people we want to
save the country and make it a safer
place in the future we're hoping that
he's the one who can save the country
for our children as defense minister and
president the Rajapaksa were credited
with crushing the Tamil Tigers in the
Civil War
got abaya faces lawsuits in the u.s. in
relation to human rights atrocities
allegedly committed during the conflict
in peacetime the Rajapakse has borrowed
billions of dollars from China for
infrastructure projects Sri Lanka sits
in the middle of strategic Indian Ocean
shipping lanes China has a 99 year lease
on a port on the southern coast
if supporters have any concerns about
that they've been put to one side what
has become important for them is to be
assured to be able to make the
assumption that I can go out of my house
I can send my children to school
whatever that there is no question of an
imminent threat against them Rajapaksa
has promised another 5 billion dollars
on new infrastructure projects if he
wins against the candidate for the
ruling coalition Sangeeth prima dasu
also has support from the Sinhala
community and he has a wider appeal
among some grassroots Tamil and Muslim
voters worried about the return of the
Rajapaksa
but he serves in a government that is
presiding over a stalling economy and
has been found responsible for ignoring
intelligence warnings that could have
stopped the Easter Sunday attacks big
hurdles for pre-med acid to overcome if
he's to achieve victory Burnett Smith al
Jazeera Colombo